[Music]
i'd really like my mother-in-law to stop
gifting me socks
i've tried explaining to her i don't
want any gifts but she won't do it any
differently i just donate them because
it feels like there's no real intention
behind the gift how do i get her to stop
gifting for the sake of gifting dude i
get socks for my mother-in-law every
year and i use them she gives me really
good i snowboard so she gives me like
really warm socks i like them so
uh
my suggestion is to appreciate the
freaking socks man no i'm kidding um i
will tell you though it reminds me the
first christmas i had with my in-laws
and they're just like the most beautiful
in-laws ever that i could possibly have
and uh
my mother-in-law gifted me like a shirt
gifted me um
some consumables but it was like the it
was the socks and the shirt is what i
remember the socks i was like oh wow
like i'm totally gonna wear these
and then the shirt i was like
i told mariah i didn't like have the
heart to like go to my mother-in-law
after
two months of meeting her because ryan i
met in november and like i was spending
christmas with with uh i just happened
to be down there and she wanted to get
me stuff so anyway i'm like mariah hey i
don't know what to tell your mom like
i'm not gonna wear the shirt right i can
donate this or maybe you can talk to
your mom to see if she wants it back and
so mariah did went back and said hey um
you know ryan just wanted me to ask you
if you wanted the shirt back because
he's probably just gonna end up donating
it yeah and she was like yeah i actually
do know someone that'll use that shirt
and i i i know who she re-gifted it to
and that that dude wears the shirt all
the time i see him wearing it a lot
really yeah so um it's so much better
than if you just held on to it right
exactly but
but i did give her the option of hey
look like i'm gonna you know now let's
say she gives her mother and all the
option like hey just so you know i've
got so many socks i'm really not gonna
wear these um you want me to find these
good home
or do you want these back to give them
to someone that might and then let the
mother-in-law decide but that's the best
way to like really kind of i think to
address that the thing is
is still they're gonna be some people in
your life who give you stuff anyway but
that's you know what who cares like
if they give you something it's yours do
with it what you want
you have the option
if this is my mug i could use it to
drink coffee or i could go donate it
right or i could find someone in the
street like hey do you drink coffee i
got a mug for you it doesn't matter or
you could break it it's yours now yes
once it's your pizza that's right
exactly you could go like if someone buy
you a bunch of mugs you want to go hit
them with baseball bats it's yours to do
that with just don't videotape it and
send it to the person who yes
here's the thing don't be a jerk about
it yeah you don't want to be a jerk
about any of this and that's why instead
of saying no no no no to christmas gifts
i say yes to the more appropriate
christmas gifts and here's what i mean
by that by setting the boundary it's not
just ba humbug no don't get me anything
because here's the honest truth
there's nothing you can get me
that i want
there's literally nothing you can get me
that will add value to my life
i already have everything i want i have
everything i need i have everything that
will add value to my life
however
that that's with material possessions
however there are certain experiences
that will radically improve my life
that i will truly enjoy and so instead
of saying no to the socks
say yes to experiences what do you want
to do what would enhance your
relationship with your mother-in-law
what type of experience would make yours
and her life better that's what i'm
going to say yes to and say yes to it in
advance and that way you don't even have
to worry about the socks hey
mother-in-law you know what i could
really use this year i would love to go
to a movie with you know this movie
comes out christmas day would you be
willing to to get that for me as a
christmas gift that point you're not
even saying no to her because you're
already saying yes to the thing you know
what add value to your life and why is
she buying the gift it's not because
gift giving is a love language that's
nonsense adding value is a love language
and your mother-in-law loves you she
wants to add value to your life you have
to show her how to add that value for
you turn those socks into sock puppets
and create an experience i think that's
what you're trying to say josh
[Laughter]
uh patrons let's see if we have any uh
quick questions from the live stream do
you have a favorite question or two that
you've collected alabama uh this is one
i think will be good this is from amanda
how do i give gifts to people who have
reacted very negatively to experience
base gifts in the past they've made it
very clear that they weren't happy
without getting a thing
yeah well
so let's say for a second that you're
not happy if i don't give you a million
dollars
then you're just gonna be not happy yeah
and that's not up to me because here's
the truth you can't make them happy only
they can make them happy yeah you can't
make them unhappy either in the same
token that's true and so i can't give
you a gift that makes you happy they get
to decide whether or not they are happy
and if that's a reaction to a gift
whether it's an experience gift a
physical gift or something else they get
to decide they also as ryan just said
they get to decide whether or not
they're going to be upset or unhappy you
cannot make them unhappy you cannot make
them upset however let me just say this
there are ways to take experiences and
consumables which people often look at
consumables as a material
good sure and it is a material good but
it has some sort of expiration date on
it send them some bandit coffee yeah you
can go to banditcoffee.com
and send them some coffee from there or
from your local
indie coffee shop not from the some
corporate
seattle-based place you you can just go
to a local indie shop you can get coffee
wine what other consumables can you get
flowers chocolates
gift cards local foods desserts
meats and cheeses dude let's say though
that like i got you an experience i was
like here's some tickets to an art
exhibit that i think you'll like and
you're like i can't believe you didn't
get me a tie clip
you know what i'd get you next christmas
i'd get you a freaking tie clip dude
that's really what brought you joy
that's really what brought meanings to
your life was a tie clip here you go
here's your tie clip
yeah i don't think i would do that still
and and here's why
um and i wouldn't be upset for you you
for doing it of course just because i
don't
i don't want to participate in the
consumerism of the holidays personally
right and so it goes against my own
values there and and so what i would say
is that
is there a way that i can create an
experience or a consumable and gift it
in a way that mimics the giving yeah of
a material possession very similar to
what i did with ella and the pineapple
that was obviously a consumable sure but
it looked like any other birthday gift
or christmas gift
and she got to open it she had the whole
experience of that and she got to enjoy
it after that as well yeah so the
question
is how can you show
this person
or not show them but you know what gift
can you give them that doesn't cross
your values yeah like josh knives
different values that's okay
um the question is what are your values
amanda
and what can you give them that that
fall within those boundaries yeah you
certainly don't want to go outside your
boundaries but
yeah it's i mean yeah
yeah josh is saying hey no i'm not going
to give in and get you a tie clip i'm
saying i would absolutely give you a tie
clip if that's what you wanted um that's
but amanda it's up to you it's not up to
josh rye that's right
and so
um what i'll tell you is that
if
you feel compelled to get them something
why do you feel compelled to get them
something
if you feel compelled to get to
something just to placate them to make
them happy
well then you yourself
are never going to be happy if you feel
like you're merely pacifying them and
you're doing something that you don't
want to do that's interesting i disagree
with that man because like when i give
my mom like the flowers and the
chocolate it is a placation like i don't
see any value in that whatsoever well
you missed the last line that i said
there oh sorry if you're doing something
you don't want to do oh right fair if
you're doing something you don't want to
do
if it goes against your values if it
goes against the person you want to be
then of course you're never going to
feel contented with that right giving
your mother flowers or chocolate does
not go against your values at all right
but if you were giving her clothes she
was going to throw away immediately
she's going to let him on fire and send
me a video of it
you would feel discontented by that sure
and and so we have to be careful here
because we can spend all of our time
trying to make other people happy not
realizing that it's actually impossible
for us to do that we can bring them
pleasure
but that pleasure does not translate
into contentment
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free